okay if you want more you can have more
but first you have to eat all this i got
salad and mac and cheese
salad and mac and cheese love salad and
mac and cheese those are two favorite
things you guys are having mac and
cheese too yeah but you know what there
is probably four different kinds of
cheeses in this and you know what else
is in it a lot of love
a lot of love
because that's what i do i cook with
love thanks for having us thank you of
course i spend a night back here
when do you want to
um
soon
yeah okay cool i get pretty excited when
jackson you know will ask mimi when can
i come over again when can i sleep over
you're very appreciative especially with
like jackson and lyla you know just
being you know a little person you know
grandma in their life i'd love it if
they just wanted my thoughts and
opinions of what's going on in their
world
what was an update on him and his you
know
legs and all that stuff supposed to be a
six month update but tori called and
they're like no he should be a little
bit more back to normal
than what it sounds like so we made it
an appointment just to check it out
there is
legitimately something wrong
you know like he isn't progressing like
they said that he would and he isn't
recovering as quickly i would not say
he's progressing even on a like he is
not progressing he complains and says it
hurts a million things ran through our
head that we're like let's just go and
see the doctor and just make sure
that there's no actual structural damage
and it's just his body is having a
harder time recovering
well if something isn't
healing right or growing right i want to
adjust especially before this new baby
comes
[Music]
you